[Applause]
it's time for drew's news your gentle
news exfoliator guaranteed to give you
that good news glow and with me at the
desk well he's got the freshest face in
news matthew
yes i marvel at your skin it's like
marble stop it please don't flirt with
me this is a place of work
sorry i know i don't want to be
inappropriate and i know i'm not
necessarily your type or maybe i am
i don't know
true that's why this works
well today beauty week continues with
yet another makeover and we're shining a
spotlight on a selfless mother and vice
principal who gives back to her
community let's meet monique jenkins
[Applause]
my name is monique jenkins i'm a native
new yorker from the bronx but i've been
living in montclair new jersey for over
25 years i am a vice principal with
newark board of education i'm a mother
of 11 year old son who has autism and
i'm a vice president of the best
community service organization in new
jersey montclair trista's my day starts
at five and then i get into bed maybe 11
30 12 o'clock in the night everything
that i want to do on a personal level
has to be scheduled weeks in advance
it's been very difficult i don't have a
lot of time for myself i haven't had a
massage in like
i want to say 10 years what i really
want is that just have somebody giving
me a consultation saying this is a look
for you you need to cut like this or a
color like this i need a whole overhaul
listen
i love this because monique's friend
from the montclair drifters are here
so tanya what do you think that this
makeover will kind of feel like from
monique it'll remind monique to take
care of monique
she does so much she is tireless she is
selfless and no one deserves this more
than monique wow okay
[Applause]
i will say
that no matter what
monique goes through i think hearing
your words might make her feel the most
beautiful today
so i am so grateful to hear those words
from you today all right well we're
going to be doing this throughout the
whole show she's in fantastic hands
she's with my friend actually right now
sharon shooter of omaha beauty
so
i'm excited that monique is in the hands
of someone who i really trust and
respect
and we're going to see the reveal at the
end of the show all right hey so we're
doing great out here uh monique is
getting ready to be baked and glam so
here are my three important tips for
getting that ultimate look firstly
brown's brows brows they frame the face
they're your best friend do not
underestimate the brows secondly contour
contour contour because that's how you
get all the dimension and that's how you
get all the frame and the shape in your
face and then finally spot treating that
foundation do not fall for that youtube
temptation of grabbing a whole bunch of
foundation and rubbing all over your
face build it up go gradual and
let it marinate
[Applause]
i'm here with makeup maven and my friend
sharon shooter
sharon you are really changing the game
of beauty with oma your beauty brand um
you even have campaigns that say that
this is beauty for people who have felt
left out and absolutely absolutely
majority of the world can relate to
feeling left out to the very singular
and monolithic idea of beauty whether
it's because of the color of your skin
who you love how your body looks like
beauty is a democracy and that's what
we're here to do send it back to the
people to determine what beauty means
and that's what i love
okay ladies and gentlemen are you ready
to see monique
all right
that is uh monique before and here we go
monique come on out
[Applause]
[Applause]
how are you hi nice to meet you thank
you so much
welcome to this beautiful energy
thank you so much
very happy very pleased
okay i asked
tanya what you think
oh my gosh monique you are beautiful
inside we always knew that outside you
were gorgeous but your makeover you have
finally taken an opportunity to take
care of monique because you take care of
every person
can i ask you a question why do you
think you put yourself last and
everybody first
because that's how i was raised my
parents were like that and my relatives
and you know the type of work that i do
as an educator
we take care of other people's children
i've been doing that for almost 30 years
and
you know that's just ingrained in me in
everything that i do and i love that and
i applaud that
but
i'm being giving messages i've been
receiving messages from really smart
people that are saying
you're not necessarily taking yourself
uh care of yourself so how do we find
the balance sharon i'm gonna ask you
because you're like amazing looking
after yourself is not a bad thing it's
not being narcissistic it is trying to
bring out your best self so that you can
be even pleasant to other people i sort
of sometimes think about my mom and the
times where she's like short with you
and and i wonder maybe if you took a spa
day
i would have got less whooping yeah
that's yeah that's one way to think
about it right well um sharon will you
share with me um really quickly what you
did with monique and yes beautiful
judging and transformation and little
beauty boost yes i mean the first part
of what i did was just let monique be
monique and that is the most important
thing right and y'all can see monique is
monique right now right um hair it was
about go big or go home right you'll see
my hair
i love big hair and thank you i wanted
us to see her face because her face is
beautiful and she owns it and i wanted
the focus to be on the face
for the styling i wanted that singed on
the waist i love a lovely belt right
there and monique is
she is so good because monique is a
survivor she's had a double mastectomy
i wanted her to feel beautiful and proud
in that and so she's got all that glam
going on and for the face if you want to
get her eyes of the star of her show so
two things we did here one is called
tight lining which you take an eyeliner
and the eyeliner becomes the star you
don't want to do too much especially if
you've got a hooded lid you want to look
very soft glam but effortless and then i
wanted to extend it all the way up there
it's called the bella hadid cat eyes you
take a contour stick and you just apply
some contour right there and it drags
your face all the way up there so we got
a little facelift up there just by doing
that and then finally accessories is the
star of the show i'm loving them earring
now let me tell you something coco
chanel says before you leave the house
look in the mirror and take one thing
off for me before i leave the house i
look in the mirror and i add one thing
on and today it was those beautiful
earrings in that ring and everything
coming together is money
well monique we want to send you to that
spa day that sharon so uh astutely
recommended um but most importantly how
do you feel i feel terrific i feel
rejuvenated ready to face the world
you know and i feel fabulous yes yes
um all right
well
i want to send you guys to like a
fabulous lunch right now because you
cannot just like take that off and go
back like you've got to just walk the
runway of life for the rest of the
afternoon is that okay yeah sure all
right fabulous okay okay well thank you
tonya and monique and sharon so much and
thank you to the roy t-lex salon um
who's gonna just pamper you and do some
of that self-care that we all suck at so
badly so thank you so much
okay tomorrow we have another amazing
makeover thank you for choosing to spend
your time with us we make this show for
you
[Music]